WOULD KNOW THAT IT WAS WHOLLY
ABSURD ON ITS FACE.
>> Tucker: JANICE DEAN IS OUR
SENIOR METEOROLOGIST HERE AT
FOX, SHE LOST BOTH OF HER
IN-LAWS AND FACILITIES LICENSED
BY NEW YORK STATE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SHE KNOWS A LOT ABOUT THIS TOPIC
AND SHE JOINS US TONIGHT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I DON’T WANT TO RUB SALT IN THIS
VERY FRESH WOUND, BUT TO HEAR
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK PASS
THE BUCK ON TO THE PRESIDENT FOR
HIS DECISION, HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THAT?
>> HE’S BLAMED EVERYBODY EXCEPT
THE PERSON THAT SIGNED THE
MANDATE, THE ORDER TO BRING
COVID PATIENTS INTO NURSING
HOMES AND THAT WAS ANDREW CUOMO.
HE SIGNED THE ORDER AT THE VERY
BEGINNING, HE SAID IF YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH WHAT HAPPENS IN
NEW YORK, YOU BLAME ME, THE BUCK
STOPS AT MY DESK.
HE HAS NEVER TAKEN ANY
RESPONSIBILITY OR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND AS YOU JUST PLAYED, HAS
BLAMED EVERYONE EXCEPT HIMSELF.
GOD, MOTHER NATURE, FOX NEWS,
BLAMED "THE NEW YORK POST,"
MOTHER NATURE, AND NEVER ENDS,
AND TODAY, HE CONTINUED TO BLAME
FOX NEWS AND SAID THERE DOESN’T
NEED TO BE AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE THE LAST
INVESTIGATION WAS DONE BY
HIMSELF AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
AND OF COURSE, HE CAME UP CLEAN.
THE PEOPLE TO BLAME FOR THE
NURSING CARE WORKERS IN THE
VISITORS, AND BY THE WAY, WE
WEREN’T ALLOWED TO VISIT MY
IN-LAWS BEFORE THEY DIED.
SO I DON’T BELIEVE THAT ONE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU LIVE IN
NEW YORK, WORK IN NEW YORK, YOUR
FAMILY WAS DEVASTATED BY THIS
DECISION, YOU HAD A CHANCE TO
TELL GOVERNOR CUOMO THAT.
>> NO, I HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK
TODAY.
I FILLED OUT ALL THE PAPERWORK,
AND I SENT LETTERS TO
ASSEMBLYMAN AND LAWMAKERS,
NEW YORK STATE LAWMAKERS FOR THE
HEARINGS TODAY, THEY WERE
ACTUALLY AUGUST THE 3RD LAST
MONDAY AND TODAY.
THEY COULDN’T FIT ME IN LAST
MONDAY, BUT THEY SAID THAT THEY
WOULD PUT ME ON TODAY TO GIVE ME
MY 5 MINUTES TO TALK ABOUT MY
IN-LAWS AND WHY I HOLD THE
GOVERNOR PARTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR DEATHS.
THAT INVITATION WAS RESCINDED
AFTER I WAS TOLD THAT THE CHAIR
SAID HE WILL HAVE YOUR
5 MINUTES, AND I NEVER GOT THAT,
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING GOOD ON
YOUR BOARD AND HAVING ME ON YOUR
PROGRAM TODAY.
>> Tucker: WE ARE DELIGHTED TO
HAVE YOU ON THIS SHOW EVEN UNDER
SAD CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE THIS,
APPRECIATE YOUR COMING ON AND